[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
two
[Music]
[ __ ]
foreign
my
foreign
hmm
we
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
your program indicates an intermission
but that is not true
um i just have to say the two saxophone
pieces that you heard
so beautifully played that that's all
them they did all they picked the music
they did all the rehearsing and uh i
think they did a fabulous job doing all
that
i welcome you my name is fred harrison
director of wind and jazz ensembles here
at mit
and uh although somewhat subtle and
somewhat not
what you heard those three pieces is
actually a little bit of a tribute
to john mcclellan wow already
so i want to before i get to that
thank a few people some things will be
happening behind me
and so i'm going to talk while those
things are happening i hope those things
are starting to happen now
are they that would be the cue
start coming out now while the full
ensemble makes its way to stage
i want to thank some key people who have
been at the heart of our support system
this entire academic year
cuco doglio mit music and theater arts
multimedia specialist
tony you can clap at the end tony de
bartolo our recording engineer
kalina schlonager and her husband isaiah
administrators for
mta michael carmichael i'm my oh boy
it's a long day and night michelle
carmichael
administrative officer for mta larry
gallagher and his entire mt
mit video productions team that has made
the dream of streaming performances
possible
with the support of neil and jane
popolardo on
may 11th we have a unique musical event
you might see on the back of your
program you might have seen a rather
large poster out front
the great clarimet summit how many of
you already have tickets to the great
clarinet summit
i'll say half of you for our visiting uh
audience online
um what is this concert
are things continue yes things are
continuing to happen behind me
um so this is i i'm not aware of any
other concert
quite like this that has happened i
won't go as far as to say there's never
been a concert like this but
it could be the case we have five major
clarinet soloists three of whom
are have been long-standing jazz uh
icons of the clarinet for many years
billy novak is a boston jazz institution
clarinetist from lexington mass has been
doing all of the major clarinet
jazz work in the boston area for 30
years uh don
byron has been on the scene a graduate
of new york conservatory
has been on the scene for at least 30
years and
really one of the most innovative and
eclectic and
uh soulful musicians on the
music scene annott cohen israeli born
fantastic clarinetist is uh newer to the
scene
and has been uh tearing up that scene in
the world of jazz and
improvisational music so that's three
people
that would seem to be enough right for a
clarinet summit but yet we have two
incredible clarinetists on our faculty
um iran ngozi uh has is newly on our
faculty the last couple of years
as a fantastic uh classical clarinetist
and
um a founder of the radius chamber
ensemble around town
and um in his spare time he creates
things like guitar hero
and also just newly a new boston
symphony orchestra program
online program note uh system and of
course there is evan zipporin
who is one of the leading clarinet
players
in the world particularly with bass
clarinet
but really has his own ensembles
performs with yo-yo ma
among many others and as i say happens
to be our
faculty head and uh and chair who's been
on this faculty for 25 years
and then on the poster it says and you
and you so how many of you play the
clarinet out there
raise your hand okay how many of you
have already signed up for the summit
how many of you don't know what i'm
talking about how many of you are
fearful
so if you play the clarinet you're
thinking i'm going to play with all
these people you just went on and on
about how wonderful they are how am i
gonna play with them
i've been playing uh for five years i've
been playing for three years
i've been playing for 45 years and i'm
in the boston symphony well guess what
you can all play on this concert because
a fabulous
musician who i will introduce a little
bit later jamshid sharifi composed a
piece
called ornament of the world that in
fact
will feature all five of these
clarinetists
plus ini oguntola who is part of the
inspiration for the whole clarinet
summit he's a junior here
at mit and a fabulous improvisational
clarinetist
um and the mit wind ensemble and the mit
festival jazz ensemble somehow we will
all fit on this stage
and then i think we're up to 70 people
signed up now i'm dreaming of 200
clarinets i know it sounds scary but
it's going to be beautiful
200 clarinets will be aligned
and they will play in this piece how
does that happen
well oh my goodness we're all ready this
is very exciting
um okay i can stop the commercial for
the clarinet summit now
and uh i know you wanted more but
i believe there's a very full mit win
ensemble and
you might see faces that are slightly
older
than college students and that's because
we have
six seventh and eighth graders from the
chenery middle school here
they are here to honor john mcclellan
who is a fantastic music educator
from the belmont public schools and he's
retiring this year after 35 years in
belmont in a number of years in other
places
before i don't tell you what we're going
to play i want to say something about
john mcclellan
the mit wind ensemble has collaborated
with the chenery middle school on
numerous occasions over the last 10 15
years
and i've personally been collaborating
with john since 1987
first interning at the chenery school
and then later teaching alongside him in
the belmont public schools he's one of
my dearest friends and colleagues and
among the greatest musicians and music
educators
i've been privileged to know and learn
from and continue to learn from
his teaching legacy in belmont is rooted
in excellence creativity kindness
deep dedication and true caring for each
individual student
and there have been thousands of them i
want to i'd like to invite two of them
to come to the stage to say a little bit
about one facet of john's teaching that
they'd like to talk about
please welcome tilly jones and irene son
hello my name is irene um this is tilly
and we are here with the chenery wind
ensemble
to celebrate our teacher john mcclellan
and his accomplishments over the past 35
years
of teaching at the chennai middle school
i'm an eighth grader at chenery and mr
mccollum's been my teacher for the past
five years now
the levels which are the reason we are
here today are
a series of exercises that mr mcclellan
created
in 1999 in order to
challenges students to take music to
another level
in order to pass the levels you have to
record yourself
playing the exercise then submit them to
mr mccollon or miss phipps
then they would decide whether the level
is good enough to pass or they would
send it back to you so that you could
try it again
once you've passed the basic 10 levels
then mr mccullen writes an
individualized level for you
that includes skills that he feels will
push you forward as a musician
in total mr mccollum's written over 550
levels that are all different in some
way
and tilly and i have each passed about
110 levels
and people ask us why do you pass so
many levels
and to be really honest we have to sit
down and think about it for a second
after thinking about it for a long time
we came to the conclusion that there are
really two main reasons
um the first reason is that mr mccollum
has helped us
to learn how
um learn the feeling of achievement
and mr mccollum's endless efforts to
keep up with all of us
and it has encouraged us to keep
playing music and reach for our goals um
the levels are a unique way to practice
our instruments and because all the
levels
are different and challenging in their
own way
it makes it more interesting to practice
the levels
um i as a player have
have improved very much
and i'm sure others here feel the same
way as i do
mr mccollum's writing has really
inspired us all and the time and thought
that he devotes into writing each and
every level
for all of his students is really
incredible
the second reason we do levels is
because levels are a way that mr
mccullen connects with his students
mr mccall knows everyone he doesn't just
know their name and what instrument they
play he understands everyone's
personality and he knows how dedicated
to music they are
he knows so much about everyone he's
able to write a piece of music that is
specifically made to match their
strengths weaknesses and character
so many people i know have just done the
level so that they could have a piece of
music
specifically written for them written by
their favorite teacher
mr mcclellan has written over 550 levels
and so many people ask us why we've done
110 levels
and although we've done 110 we've only
passed a fifth of the amount of levels
he's actually written
mr mccullen is one of the most
hardworking and inspiring teachers we've
ever had and we all just want to thank
him for making the chennai a better
place for the past 35 years
so while i'm not going to tell you what
we're about to play i will tell you that
the composer is john mccollum
the arranger is kenneth amos the
commissioning body of these this
three movement work is palms parents of
music supporters
to parents of music students belmont's
community music support group
and we thank them for making what you're
about to hear possible and i want to
thank palms president
kimberly carlisle and particularly cindy
estes membership chairperson of palms
who has been at the front lines for this
whole project
lastly a huge thanks to sharon phipps
john's
co-director at the chenery school who
put enormous energy
both logistically and uh musically
into this whole project i also just want
to thank the chennai
sixth seventh and eighth graders who
participated in this 50 of them
they're amazing people as you will hear
and you've already heard
and it was just a complete joy for me to
come back home as it were to belmont
amazing young people please enjoy this
three movement tribute
to john mcclellan arranged by kenneth
amos and performed by the chenery
and mit when not songs
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
bye
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
london
how many of you are
and there's 50 people behind me that
knew all about this
and yet not a word was spoken
and as i recognize level 789
thankfully i stopped at level 5 writing
them for band
so now i don't have to worry about those
and i believe the woodwind quintet a
couple of months ago
played level six so we're almost done
everyone
where's ken amos
well thank you immensely ken amos
but who where's sharon phipps she's not
getting out of this
sharon if you don't want to speak into
mike maybe get tilly and irene to talk
for you
i am deeply impressed thank you very
much
students of belmont students of mit and
the amazing dr harris but most of all
sharon thanks everyone
now it's interesting